هذا واكد رئيس
الاوكرانيسكي على صفحته في تلجرام لو ناقش
في اتصال هاتفيين مع نظيره الفرنسي
التعاون في مجالا الدفاع والطاقه الى جانب
النقاط العشري لتحقيق السلام وفقا لصيغه
الاوكرانيه وقال زينسكي ان نظيره الفرنسيه
من وين ماكرون يدعم موسيقى السلامه التي
كان قد طرحها في قمه العشرين في نوفمبر
الماضي وضف ذلك انه ناقش ايضا مع الرئيس
التركي رجب طيب اردوغان امكانيه توسيع ممر
التصدير في البحر الاسود ووصفه بالامر
بالاهميه العالميه
اليوم وناقشنا قضايا الدفاعي والطاقه
والاقتصادي والدبلوماسيه من السوق الخطوات
ونستعد لتنفيذ معادلهنا للسلام كما تحدثت
اليوم مع الرئيس تركيا
في البحر الاسود وشكرته على دعم مبادرتنا
الانسانيه حبوب من اوكرانيا واتفقنا على
بعض الخطوات المشتركه المهمه للمست للقريب
الاسبوع القادم سيكون مهما قمه المجموعه
السابعه ومؤتمر في فرنسا بشان انتعاش
اوكرانيا واستقرارها في الشتاء واحداث على
مستوى الاتحاد الاوروبي مستعدون للمشاركه
ونتوقعون نتائج مهمه